[Musik]
als wir wollen der heutigen im übungs
sitzung an der frage anknüpfen die wir
im seminar gestellt hatten nämlich ob
neuronale netzwerke künstliche neuronale
netz wege auch denken können und dazu
müssen natürlich jetzt werden was denken
ist dass intelligenz ist die frage wo
heute klären was sagst du ich habe mich
auch gefragt was intelligenz ist weil
mir das nicht sichtlich schien ja meine
abgrenzung gemacht zum zur
rechenleistung von computern und das
heißt dass der heutige stand der technik
eigentlich gar keine intelligenz
aufweist wir reden immer von k aber es
gibt es gar nicht weil es momentan nur
rechenleistungen sind aber nicht das
andere was menschen noch machen sowas
wie kreativität kunstwerke die momentan
nicht hergestellt werden sind ja auch
ein rechenleistungen vielleicht so was
fehlt die motivation fehlt zum beispiel
das ist vielleicht das hat motivation
was mit intelligenz zu tun
ja also genau nicht so lange stelle ich
mir auch und vielleicht haben die
anderen teilnehmer unserer unseres
territoriums noch ein paar ideen
zu sagen dass man sich an die
veränderten geben
die kosten anpassen kann und man sieht
ihr das immer so computerprogramme oder
systeme ich ziemlich gut aber immer in
einer bestimmten sache sind also deshalb
glaube ich es ist auch also man kann
sich ja alle möglichen computergestützte
systeme vorstellen wie viel besser sind
als erster mensch aber wie gesagt nur in
dem einen bereich und deshalb würde man
ja nicht sagen das ist sonderlich
intelligent ist also wenn zum beispiel
so eine software irgendwie
handschriftliche sachen total gut
erkennt kann er aber immer noch nicht
jetzt irgendwie freundschaften hin wie
sowas vielleicht so eine
ganzheitlichkeit von fähigkeiten also
dass man nicht sagt man ist in dieser
einen sache kann man wasser in
verschiedenen verschiedene
sinneswahrnehmungen china in sachen
erkennen tun denken genau das würde ich
zum beispiel schon als wesentliche
unterschied sehen also im vergleich zum
aktuellen stand also das könnte sich
ändern
die fahrzeiten dieses trends kinder des
netzwerks so komplex dass die wir davor
gar nicht von möglichkeiten
und je dichter und vernetzt dass so ein
netz ist umso mehr züge lassen sich hier
stimmen
und hier muss man glaube ich einfach
noch ein bisschen ausprobieren das kam
jetzt gar nicht unbedingt apriori also
vor allem fans sagen wir müssen einfach
immer weitere informationen einspeisen
solchen letzten dezember multiplizieren
jetzt noch komplexer machen noch erlaubt
akten diese netze und dann schauen was
dabei herauskommt wenn wir so einem
egoistischen ansatz vertreten
wir sorgen dafür dass das jetzt komplex
ist maximal komplex maximal vernetzt und
waren einfach was den effekt auftritt
das wäre zu der experimentelle ansatz zu
den ich eigentlich war es ja auch gesagt
bei netzwerken dass das irgendwie hat
das dir bei neuronalen netzwerken das
netz relevant erscheint als gesamtheit
was ist wie würdest du das wird ein
standpunkt bezüglich keitany kann es
mehrere verschiedene karten geben in
einem neuronalen netzwerke also wenn das
hast du ja auch heute vormittag gesagt
oder heute mittag der name ist wo wir
über das autonome fahren geredet habe ja
gesagt das sind autonome systeme also
proteste autonom viert dass das
eigentlich auch nur so ein knotenpunkt
in zum größeren netz ist und da ist es
gar nicht separat isoliert gesehen
werden kann
und das würde ich sehr unterstützt also
dass wir die netzwerke tagen ganz
radikal denken sollten und das wäre so
mein stichwort der enter objektivität
die sind so die kategorie sich heute
geprägt habe also alles
steht mit allem in verbindung jeder
gegenstand kein prinzipielles am
knotenpunkt eines größeren netzwerks
werden
er speist seine information mit ein und
wir wissen am ende nicht was durch
dieses neue mitglied dieses netzes am
ende dabei rauskommt aber seit
integrations kraft hat das jetzt alles
was äußerlich ist wird zu einem neueren
mit auch klar und dann schaffen wir
jetzt aber auch zu sagen dass wir nicht
nur von dem nationales netzwerk der
autonomen autos wegen sondern die sind
dann auch verbunden mit kühlschränken
und video kam gasgehalt also sozusagen
neuronale netz über die die grenzen der
einsatzgebiete hinaus als der trend zu
begreifen also nicht nur neuronale netz
im sinne von texterkennung so nennt sich
in jedem bereich der erkenntnis was
überhaupt anerkenntnis interessant wird
und dieses netz eingespeist und am ende
die der endpunkt wert ist das wäre ein
riesen setzt hätten wie ist internet der
dinge mit ganz verschiedenen regionalen
separaten künstlichen intelligenzen die
aber aus dem gesamtblick mit zusammen
wird also nicht mehr getrennt ich glaube
dass das eine eigenschaft der
digitalität digitalisierung ist das
vormals getrennten plötzlich in
beziehung gesetzt werden kann instanz
ohne beziehung dass durch das in
beziehung treten neue erkenntnisse und
neue realität geschaffen das natürlich
dazu frage ist wie wir den begriff der
intelligenz definieren das ist das eine
wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel von dem vom
autonomen fahren ausgeht und wo wir
sagen ich glaube das bezeichnet man als
connected living und wenn die autos
unternommen
kommunizieren und wenn ich mir irgendwie
in der natur zum beispiel die fischer
als beispiele ansehen
die verfügen über neuronale netzwerk wir
haben eine schwarmintelligenz davon geht
man glaube ich dass das heißt sie sind
untereinander verbunden auto also für
sich für sich selber während zum
beispiel makrelen die irgendwie
schwachen auftreten wäre eine makrele
für sich selber verloren im schwarm
können sie sich halt in
anführungsstrichen intelligent bewegen
und verhalten
aber inwiefern spricht man also dass es
irgendwo rudimentäre intelligenz und
inwiefern wenn man von einer intelligenz
bei einem künstlichen objekt im sinne
von einem auto ausgeht also wenn wir von
künstlichen neuronalen netzwerken
sprechen und die sind untereinander
verbunden und noch mit anderen
gegenständen
aber was bedeutet da intelligent ich mir
scheint es so dass ein auto an sich oder
irgendeine software ein programm ohne
den tod eines menschen überhaupt ja erst
gar nicht beginnen
ich glaube dass in die gäste dort
probleme lösen zu können
das setzt voraus dass etwas etwas ein
problem wahr ist und jetzt kann man sich
natürlich fragen hat ein auto ein bus
sei von einem problem
ich glaube ein auto hat gar kein so
viele gegenstände für dies wird die welt
nicht problematisch und erst da wird im
web nur die welt zu einem problem wird
also ängste oder bedürfnisse interesse
der auftritt erst da kann überhaupt
intelligenz in gang gesetzt werden oder
entwickelt werden um dieses problem zu
lösen
so würde jetzt intelligent definieren
als problemlöser und strategie das setzt
natürlich voraus dass für einen
gegenstand oder für eine instanz etwas
überhaupt zu einem problem wird und
problembewusstsein scheint mir nicht
überall gegeben zu sein
außerdem entstand so das vorgegebene ja
dass man also mir scheint dass problemen
oder dann wirklich vital oder mit
interessenverbänden auftreten wenn wir
ist mit formen des lebens zu tun haben
und jetzt kann sich natürlich fragen
kann man neuronale netze oder künstliche
die gänge zu trainieren so etablieren
dass sie die struktur des lebens auf
zahlen aufweist also dass sie das ein
neuronales selbst in der zweck an sich
schon lebendig genau durch die
netzwerkstruktur das genau dass es
eigene bedürfnisse hat ein interessen
hat das was gehört alles zum leben zum
leben gehört dazu dass es sich auf sich
selbst bezieht es ein organismus also
eingeschlossen und das ziel ist in
europa das netz was den output wieder
als input gibt als ein geschlossenes
al qosi besondern rückgekoppelt das
system so müsste das neuronale netz
aussehen geschlossen und es müsste
vielleicht sogar haupt darauf
interessiert sein
zu wachsen als in neue bereiche sich
einzuverleiben
vielleicht so eine art stoffwechsel
herzustellen kann man sich auch
abstrakter decken und es müsste mehr
innen nach außen grenze kennen also
müsste sich abgrenzen können von anderen
teilen des netzes auch wenn es damit
zugleich wieder in bezug steht und dann
könnte man sie natürlich in letzter
konsequenz überlegt ob man damit sie
sich auch vor pflanzen also dass sowohl
alle zehn kleine regionale netze aus
sich in zellen entlassen oder das nur
wenn alle anderen netze auffressen oder
schlucken dass es zusammenarbeit kampf
zur wahl aus der fit ist kommt solche
strukturen könnte man sich überlegen
wenn das in regionalen und jetzt einen
selbst interesse hat ein vitales
interesse hat zu überleben alle lebens
begriff scheint ganz wichtig zu sagen
und die frage ist als er es eine höhere
stufe frage die eine frage ist können
die idance simulieren
da würde ich sagen das geht aber für die
intelligenz müssen wir noch das problem
voraussetzen das problem müssen wir von
außen an die intelligenz der antrag und
wir müssen jetzt überlegen können wir
neuronale wechselte künstliche
intelligenzen erzeugen die selbst
probleme entwickeln für die selbst etwas
zu ihren eigenen problemen wird und das
würde voraussetzen dass diese signale
netz lebendig ist dass wir malteser
also ich kann mir allerdings schwer
damit eine maschine als autonomes
gegenüber zu verstehen ich habe es so
dieses also der menschheit der zum
beispiel diesen selbsterhaltungstrieb
viele andere lebewesen auch
wahrscheinlich alle und es könnte eine
maschine denke ich auch haben aber
glaube ich auch wieder ist eine reine
vermutung auch wieder nicht ohne den
externen input dass ich halt
programmieren du möchtest überleben du
möchtest dich vermehren fortpflanzen
oder andere neuronale netze übernehmen
die einfälle
ich habe das gefühl dass es immer nur
über den über etwas externen ja
funktioniert und ich frage mich auch
wenn es wenn der stein im rollen ist
dass die maschinen selber lernen können
sich berechtigte probleme stellen können
aber irgendwie bleibt das mir soweit ich
das durch denken kann muss der stein ins
rollen gebracht werden und das sind es
am ende der mensch der das tut richtig
das ist das thema autonomie und freiheit
also um das hängt auch mit dem lebens
begriff zusammen ich würde sagen das
leben auf dem basalen ebene bereits eine
form von autonomie hat autonomie dem sie
dass man sich selbst ein gesetz gibt das
einem selbst etwas zu einem problem wird
falls man selbst gefolgt
also organismen sind selbst bezügliche
systeme sie geben sich selbst welche
regeln und probleme vor oder sie
reagieren auf probleme die für sie zum
problem werden und genauso könnte man
jetzt sagen dass autonome systeme eben
formen des lebens cdu hatten sie
komplexer sind die setzen sich höher
stufigen zwecke und ziele die sie dann
verfolgen also wir kommen glaube ich
nicht drum herum ein begriff des lebens
zu entwickeln
als basis für künstliche intelligenz ihr
könnt glaube ich keine künstler die
lizenz erzeugen allein auf was für
neuronalen netzen weil wir hier immer
wie sie glaube ich zu recht gesagt haben
interessen digitale die simulieren
müssen einspeisen müssen die stamm für
uns und er ist da wo ein system selbst
alten interessen wie tat folgt da können
wir sagen dass lebt und wo es diese
interessen vertritt oder auf einem
höheren komplexitätsgrad voll da können
wir dann davon sprechen dass es sogar
autonomen oder freien ist und da ist man
dann also ganz nachdrücklich an
menschlichen täter an die frage ist
erreicht das war jetzt sozusagen thema
intelligenzen selbstbewusstsein weil ich
glaube eine frage die bionord gestellt
das war nach dem ursprung dessen oder um
dann auch die frage ob der ursprung
notwendig dafür ist ob man ein
neuronales netzwerk sei es digital oder
biologisch ob man das als wirklich
intelligent bewertet weil wir würden uns
ja selbstbewusstsein zu schreiben und
also der mensch würde sich sechs uhr ist
es dann zu schreiben weiß aber gar nicht
woher das kommt wissen ja nicht warum
wir existieren
was der grund und ursprung unseres
denkens unsere fähigkeit ist das heißt
angenommen
die werden auch programme von irgendwem
oder es gibt ein täuscher dämon ein gott
was auch immer dann dann dann ist unser
selbstbewusstsein jetzt in der eigenen
fraktion so hoch das wird immer noch von
also dass wir uns selber dass
intelligenz zu schreiben aber andere
neuronale netzwerke wie die ki vom auto
oder oder vom handy oder von google
die das gar nicht wahrnehmen weil wir
nur untereinander sind da ist sein
zweiter punkt wo ich meine vielleicht
wirst du dass die neuronale digitalen
neuronale netzwerke irgendwann auch ein
bewusstsein einem bewusstsein erschaffen
und in sich tragen was mir gar nicht
erkennen können ja das ist das sowieso
das problem bei jedem bewusst sein ja
als ja auch nicht wie es ist gut
du weißt nicht wie es ist nichts was du
kannst nur darauf schließt aber wenn ich
mich irgendwie wenn ich das gesicht
verziehen oder irgendwie ich so reile
oder so dann kannst du sagen da muss
jetzt irgendjemand muss jetzt der- jörg
schmerzt weil bei mir das genau so hat
schließt auf basis von technologien
aber es könnte ja sein dass es neuronale
netz oder künstlich die gänse die gar
keine möglichen signale aussenden dies
die erlauben rückschlüsse ziehen
also wenn sie sich überlegen sie
begegnen auf einem fremden planeten
neuen lebensformen darstellt
wie kann ich sie dem als lebensform
erkennen sie müssten irgendwie anzeichen
dafür haben dass er gewisse ziele zwecke
verfolgt werden so was wie streben eine
intensität aber sie können eigentlich
nur mit den kategorien diese fremden
lebensformen erkennen die menschliche
natur ist beziehungsweise zu beschreiben
genau das nennt man den eindruck home
office muss also wir haben alles zu
gattungsgrenzen dass wir auch tiere
letzten die immer nach menschlichen
maßstab gemessen
es ist ambivalent einerseits gibt es
dann die tendenz des antriebs centris
muss dass wir also uns zum mars stand
erheben normativ dass wir glauben wir
seien von bedeutung
aber der vorteil besteht darin dass wir
eben gingen immer schon geneigt sind
gewisse phänomene oder einstellung oder
eigenschaften zu verstehen die wir auch
anderen menschen unterstellen
und es ist so ein bisschen so eine art
von induktion oder vielleicht sogar noch
genauer abdruck zion also wir
postulieren etwas bis jetzt in eine
krise und die ist aber nur erschlossen
und von der reduzierten wird hier
und so funktioniert das jedenfalls wenn
wir glauben dass sich die regionen zu
verhalten dass tiere schmerz haben gegen
den immer von unseren menschlichen
fahren und das wird natürlich sehr
schwierig dann wenn es um neuronale netz
also künstliche dinge bei natürlich
lebensform ist es immer noch leichter an
traktor auf wissen muss zu vertreten
weil diese tiere eben mit uns als
natürliche leben teilen aber bei
neuronalen netzen die künstlich erzeugt
sind oder auf siliziumbasis also nicht
auf kohlenstoffbasis ist jetzt viel
schwieriger den antrieb office muss wird
das thema juristisch anzubringen weil ja
die strukturen völlig anders sind sie
zwar vielleicht motiviert dann aber es
ist immer noch ganz anders werden
also wir haben da einfach epidemischen
probleme überhaupt das sind ja ja so ist
das an sich problematisch also das ist
jetzt mal natürliche lebewesen kann
dieser anthropomorphe muss ja auch zu
problemen führen beispielsweise kenne
ich das wären rund vermeintlich für uns
grinst ist es aber für ihn eine
drohgebärde also man kann ja sachen
falsch interpretieren weil wir sozusagen
von unserem standpunkt aus betrachtet
aber ich finde das an sich auch voll
spannend dieses konzept der ähnlichkeit
wenn man kann sich ja auch vorstellen
das sagen wir dieses menschen ähnlich
aussieht und man sie zum beispiel
jemanden vor stellt er das nicht weiß
und ob man dann weil wir sie gibt wie
sie gemeint haben man ja nicht mit
gewissheit wissen kann ob so wie ich
denke mein gegenüber auch denkt also man
geht ja immer nur so von diesen
ähnlichkeit konzept aus also
man denkt sich ja sieht menschlich aus
da wird dann wohl wahrscheinlich auch so
schmerzempfinden oder denken wie ich und
bei dem gedanken experiment wärs ja
sozusagen doppelt schwierig weil man ja
auch nicht weiß ob es ein echter mensch
ist oder nur so eine partie wie mainz
ist eine gewisse zeit bis man checkt das
ist überhaupt gleicht kein mensch sein
könnte weil du so die erwartung hast es
müsste jetzt ein mensch mit allen
bekannten wurde oder halt in dem sinne
dass du es gar nicht mehr unterscheiden
kannst wenn man nun nach dieser
ähnlichkeit geht also stell dir jetzt
mal ja so eine ki vor die halt einfach
wie ein mensch agiert und du weißt es
aber nicht dann würdest du ja glaub ich
auch nicht auf den gedanken kommen zu
denken dass sozusagen das gegenüber
keinen kamm bewusstsein hat oder nicht
denken kann
außer es gibt halt natürlich
auffälligkeiten wo das dann irgendwie
raus kommt weil es nicht menschen
typisch ist und du hattest von
vorstellungen geredet initiator für
dieses beispiel dass wir uns auch dinge
vorstellen können die gar nicht da sind
ja ja und da kam mir dann vielleicht
eine extremere gratwanderung wäre zu
sagen diese dieses wesen also schaut aus
wie ein mensch und kann nur bestimmte
fähigkeiten des menschen zum beispiel
smalltalk aber alles andere kann es gar
nicht
und dass dann das war doch das ist jetzt
die frage meinst du dann dass wir es
auch so viel vorstellungskraft haben
dass wir lange im glauben bleiben das
ist ein mensch der da ausschaut wie ein
mensch und smalltalk mit uns führt aber
sonst nichts kann weil wir halt uns das
vorstellen
also ich habe mich meinte das schon
dahin gegen das jetzt man sich ja schon
vorstellen kann dass es alles mögliche
kann also nur wenn es eine ki gebe die
einfach wie sozusagen von außen wie wir
das wahrnehmen
genau wie ein mensch agiert ob es dann
auch ein mensch für uns ist
vorausgesetzt du weißt nicht ob es eine
karte oder ein mensch ist das was macht
man dann also weil wie gesagt wir haben
wir nur sozusagen den bezug zu einem
anderen menschen durch sachen die wir
sozusagen mit unseren sinnen wahrnehmen
und das konzept der ähnlichkeit also ich
wüsste jetzt nicht wie man das problem
sozusagen auch die leicht lösen könnte
wir gehen hier immer so wenn man
natürlich von dem roboter ausgeht der
irgendwie dann so metallen und komisch
aussieht dann hat man da immer diese
grenze aber ich meine dass das setzen
nur weil wir noch nicht so weit sind
dass wir quasi die wirklich guten
menschliche darstellen können so alles
scheint das ips technologie also das
erkennen von dingen in der digitalität
eine neue herausforderung wird weil ganz
neue situation entstehen bisher noch
nichts zu tun haben und also mitten im
zentralen des lebens zu hängen viele
neurowissenschaft oder
naturwissenschaftlern machen meinen
augen den fehler zu glauben künstlich
künstliche intelligenz nicht auf basis
von leben realisieren zu können
also künstliche intelligenz wirklich
künstlich zu realisieren
ich glaube dass man immer ein messtrupp
tor des lebens braucht als basis auf
deren wirkliche künstliche intelligenz
auch autonom geld kann solange wir es
nicht schaffen leben zu können sich zu
modellieren
dass wir es zum beispiel auf
siliziumbasis
realisieren können wird das ganz schwer
möglich auch roboter wirklich autonomen
zurück kunst zu zu rekonstruieren und
dazu muss man jetzt eben wieder die
philosophie befragen weil die biologie
wie mir scheint gar keinen richtigen
begriff des lebens hat das ist jetzt
eine starke these aber diejenige
disziplinen die sich wirklich mit dem
begriff des lebens auseinander setzen
zahlt die philosophie und nicht die
biologie dazu möchte ich so was wie
selbst geschlossene systeme so was wie
auto praxis das waren im beton maturana
vielleicht kennen das die hier
anwesenden oder die zuhörer mit einer
varela das waren so halbe philosophen
das waren zwar auch biologen aber die
werden ganz stark in philosophischen
kontexte rezipiert weiterer punkt ist
systemtheorie verhalten komplexer
systeme strich würde im ergebnis muss
das ist auch letztendlich ein
philosophisches terra was nicht heißt
dass nicht andere disziplinen damit noch
zu tun haben können und das war sie noch
genannt hatten war schwarm intelligenz
also kann es sein dass bestimmte tiere
als einzelne individuen keine
intelligenz hervorbringen spricht keine
problemlösungskompetenz aber im schlamm
und der summe plötzlich erstaunliche
lösungen finden das findet man eben
manchmal ameisen zum beispiel also
ameisenhügel das sind ganz komplexes
system und wenn ich dann meinen finger
rein steht dann passiert das und dann
das gleichgewicht im kollektiv
aufrechterhalten das scheint auch so ein
bisschen sonne analogie zum neuronalen
netzes so eine ameise ist wenn wir genug
neuronale netze neuronen zusammenpacken
dann steht sie also ein vitaler ameisen
und ja fast eine eigene lebensform
dasteht
und da ist mir jetzt klar gekommen als
kontrast dazu ja der lebensform der
tintenfisch gerne einen sehr intelligent
ist als ein körper und dann total
erstaunliche leistungen folgen der tv
hat ja mehrere gehirne gerne an
verschiedenen orten das auch interessant
also wir sollten nicht immer so vom
menschlichen beispiel ausgeben so ein
zentrales gehirn
natürlich ist bei dem meeting sind die
verschiedenen gehirne miteinander
koordiniert sind halt einen klumpen die
dann wiederum große netzwerk bilden wir
sollten nicht immer so tun dass wir hier
so ein zentrales braucht gut wir haben
ja als menschen auch das rückenmark das
ist ja auch noch eine verlängerung des
gern kleine entstanden und so weiter und
so fort
aber wir könnten da diese netzwerke dann
noch wie weiter fasst ich würde es gerne
abschließen und zwar dachte ich mir
nämlich der einzige unterschied zwischen
im ameisenhaufen tintenfisch wäre ja
dann nur die scheinbare körperliche
distanz oder zusammengefügt haid und
dann kann man sagen es ist es ein
neuronales netz ist eben sogar in ganz
vielen einzelnen gegen die physisch
scheinbar auseinander serie der
ameisenhaufen aber ebenso als ganzes
formiert tintenfisch aber dann auch
wieder ganz in die gesundheit wenn man
ganz in die molekulare ebene schaut
haben wir auch abstände schon wieder
zwischen bei den synapsen nahm mir auch
abständen und es gibt nie geben
arbeitsaufwand sind im größeren das
finde ich in sehr guten gedanken dass du
sagst letztendlich sind alles alle
lebensformen vernetzen
die können dichter oder weniger dicht
gepackt zeigen aber letztendlich hängen
sie alle zusammen und jetzt ist halt die
frage durch was wir diese zusammenarbeit
stiftet ich glaube dass der zusammenhang
durch ein problem gestiftet durch ein
kontext des interesses und nur
lebendiger systeme haben probleme der
tagung kontexte von interesse und
ameisen haben einen treffer hinter leben
sie wurden nicht fortpflanzen und
solange mir das bringt mich wieder
zurück auf den punkt zu sagen wir nicht
künstlichen intelligenzen interessen
einpflanzen oder selbst interessen
entwickeln lassen
so lange werden die systeme auch nie
wirklich lebendig sein und nie wirklich
höhere intelligenz übrigens vollziehen
können aber diese netzwerke banken
ist richtig und schauen sie dann künftig
eine sache die nächst das internet
wieder letzten wieder dieses künstlich
intelligent können sich netzwerke können
ins internet gespeist werden und damit
wird das internet wieder zum neuronalen
netz letztendlich und also ich glaube
dass diese netzwerke danke eben ganz
zentral ist und das bedeutet eben auch
dass was nicht dann hier diese interop
jeck titel genannt haben dann machen
einen link raten jetzt in dieses die
tore auch zweimal ganz oben rechts
sitzung in der heutigen sitzung im
winter objektivität genannt hat man gute
22 50 das scheint die struktur des
netzes zu sehen
ein tänzchen zum beispiel bei dem myzel
was unter der erde liegt kann man das
schön als personal ist jetzt viele
fragen pilze sind ja wieder pflanzen
noch tiere sondern sie sind ja was
drittes bild sind dass er ganz eigene
kategorie
und sie haben auf jeden fall eine ganz
ganz ganz interessante lässt das ist
auch sein verdienst das leben
hinweis die fragen setzt eben flexibel
so ein pilzgeflecht problemlösungen
erreichen kann also wie flexibles auf
probleme reagiert kommunikation findet
ihr müsst untersuchen wie informationen
verarbeitet wird das muss man eben
prüfen und jemand letztendlich sind die
auch bei pflanzen ecm
informationsverarbeitung und das für
mich eben zunächst an dem wir haben
neben dem netz gedanken und wir haben
informations getan und wenn wir
informationen weit genug fassen dann ist
information eigentlich einfach nur das
was für uns von interesse und das was
zum lösen von problemen erforderlich ist
das heißt wir können information und
leben wieder ganz eng aufeinander
beziehen
ein system wird nach information
verlangen nach input verlangen oder auf
input ausgerichtet sein wenn es ein
problem ab was es lösen möchte schauen
sie mal wie wollen sie denn ein
künstliches neuronales netz dahin
bringen dass es für import sie müssen
das neuronale netz immer füttern mit mit
lernt dem textkorpus aber das neuronale
netz würde nie sagen ich will jetzt hier
aber mal bitte jetzt mir dieses die
daten selbst suchen es würde sich selbst
suchen scheint es als würde sie immer
von außen benötigt und zwar deswegen
weil es kein eigenes immanent des
intrinsisch das interesse hat spricht
weil das nichtleben freuen war es ja
auch in der sitzung so dass du mal dass
es gibt angegebenen hood bei einem nein
derzeit gegebenen output und das
dazwischen macht das neuronale netzwerk
der hand selbst und das wäre ja dann das
erkennen dass erkennen selektieren vom
input zum gewünschten output sowie bei
den straßenschildern zu erkennen bastelt
von diesen haufen bildern lassen alles
straßenschilder avancen alles katzen
wir müssen natürlich auch noch
trainieren das ist noch ein punkt aber
wir müssen es eben auch trainieren
häufig die frage ist gibt es nur unter
netze die sich selbst trainieren mit
sicherheit kann man sich das mini vans
rückgekoppelt ist oder sorgen der
ausgabe werde eingegeben wird und das
ist einfach schaut dass der sollwert und
ich ändere meine parameter eigenständig
bis dieser soll wird eben am meisten
erreicht das gibt es eine eingabe gibt
es eine ausgabe der ausgaben spricht
nicht wert wenn wird die ausgabe wieder
eingegeben und da wird solange variiert
beste soll werde reicht wissen aber der
sollwert er wird von außen eingegeben
das netz hat keinen eigenen so werthmann
es kein interesse hat weil es keine
normativität aufbringen kann und sie
sehen mit interesse ist auch schon ganz
gut er so was wie normativität
gesprochen hatte dass uns etwas
verbindlich ist also zum ziel unseres
handelns man kann jetzt genauso gut vor
allem handelt überhaupt anders
ich würde sagen nein warum nicht weil es
kein eigenes intrinsische selbst gesetzt
interesse das interesse kopf aus wir
haben nur wenn wir ziele verfolgen mit
internationalität die uns liegen die für
uns selbst bedeutet sie das mal alles
scheint mir keinen empfängnis keine
gefühle für bedeutsamkeit kein interesse
kurz gesagt also das neuronale märz wie
das heutzutage
genommen haben und dafür wäre eben
notwendig dass wir in das netz so
gelingt das ist lebendig und das ist
eben 30 haupt sich selbst gezogen ist
ein interesse und das ist die spannende
frage wie wird das hinbekommen
glauben sie denn es gibt so ein 1 1
eigenschaften das leben ausmacht war
dann könnte man sich ja vorstellen dass
das nur eine frage der zeit ist dass man
weiß ich selbsterhaltungstrieb dass man
das quasi ein um dann wieder anders als
leben nahmen oder ground das ist gar
nicht so zu fassen weil ich spüre noch
dazu führen dass jungen saison schon den
gedanken weil wir ja das kanalnetz
selber kreiert das finde ich jetzt nicht
so viel anders wie bei einem
menschlichen leben weil ich meinen
sorgen wir auch aktiv eingestellt sagt
sonst braucht nicht unbedingt aber er
hat der simulation jedenfalls davon der
also es muss jetzt etwas passieren ja
das leben geschichte ist sozusagen
posten nicht ziehen nichts genommen
und natürlich ist das die eine sache mit
aktiv aus programmieren oder alten
menschliches ziemlich unterschiedlich
aber auch so sagen darf sagte neben ist
es ja auch ein aktiver
ich glaube dass wir es nicht mit solchen
externen parametern hinbekommt das wird
also was einprogrammieren seine müssen
schauen dass wir die grundstruktur haben
die auf sich selbst bezogen ist da
müssen wir anfangen wir müssen irgendwie
filmen oder entdecken oder erzeugen eine
struktur die aufsichtsräte beziehen ist
das könnten wir zum beispiel erreichen
den wir pflanzen ab dem ihr pflanzgut
beobachten
also packt an der schwelle von der
materie zum leben da muss man nach
schlafen sind der übergang wird es ja
gar nicht so sehr fließend offizieren
hat dieser übergang vom loser materien
organisationen und dann zu taktisch zu
aminosäuren und so also dass wir wir
haben komplexe moleküle moleküle werden
die moleküle komplexer und ab wann
würden wir sagen ja
leben zu tun bakterium ist das schon
leben ja offensichtlich antibiotika
nehmen wir die bakterien loswerden
wollen
bios steht das leben tritt aber alle
sollten wir müssen glaube ich schon
nächste übergang von sona - soll zu
einem bakterium diese entscheidende
schritt was findet statt und das müssen
wir schaffen müssen wir dann
rekonstruieren auf basis von eben
vielleicht nicht mehr kohlenstoff eben
silizium etwas anderen und das dann
neuronal modellieren
dann ist die ansätze diese
selbstbezüglichkeit ok und dieser
gedanke kommen das leben ja nicht
automatisch bedeutet dass man dem auch
noch gewisse rechte zu jetzt zb pflanzen
dabei geben
auch bei pflanzen alles wieder stichwort
nur über das netz alle lebens organismen
sind miteinander vernetzt wenn wir ihm
regenwälder zerstören und zu stellen wir
eben den haushalt der welt
das geht eben nicht nur um biologie ist
es geht und ökologisch ist unser
ökosystem das heißt alle pflanzen steht
nicht nur in ihrem verbund sonst
interagieren das bestehende
wechselwirkung mit wie größeren kontext
die wir manchmal gar nicht absehen und
dann
wenn man so viel abgeholzt haben merken
wir dass das ganze bio oder öko system
in ungleichgewicht kommt aber sicherlich
ist leben als solches würde ich sagen
gibt es im pflanzlichen zellen noch
nicht so normativ bewährte werben dass
es um jeden preis geschützt werden muss
wo es arbeite habe ich schwierig wird
wird wirklich wo leidensfähigkeit ins
spiel kommen ist der ethische fragen zb
kann man sich fragen können ameisen
schmerz leiden
ich weiß es nicht ästhetische frage ja
mein tipp bis vor kurzem fliegen könnten
keinen schmerz leid und jetzt hat man
herausgefunden dass diese
überlebenskampf von fliegen wenn sie an
einem fliegengitter kleben oder sind
fliegenfänger kleben dass es für die
fliege schrecklich sein muss der hatte
überlebenskampf stattfindet und ja und
jetzt geht man davon weg solche die
jetzt zu verkaufen
das ist ganz interessant weil es gibt ja
wirklich von der zeit her betrachtet so
eine tendenz dass die die grenze immer
weiter abgesetzt wurde
früher dachte man ihm nur menschen seien
schmerz empfindet oder auch nur
schützenswerte dann jetzt ist man ihn
zugegangen immer weiter zu senken
festgestellt hat durch erkenntnisse dass
eben andere lebensform sehr wohl schmerz
empfinden können und mir ist die frage
wie weit unter mann geben können
ich glaube dass da eine rolle spielt das
zentralnervensystem spielt eine große
rolle für schmerz empfinden wir müssen
das dann schließen durch irgendwelche
neuronalen phänomene die irgendwie zu
was den schmerz
finden als kurat wasserstoff ist auch
alles elektrische einzel
ja aber sie müssen eben so rezipiert
werden rezeptoren die das dann das
zielwasser reize und so das wird das als
ein schmerzempfinden neuronal erklärt
das besagt dieser neuronale befund
deutet darauf hin dass es hier bei
schmerzen und handelt aber dies
übergänge schwierig dabei sind quasi
haben zustimmt die wir nie direkt
beobachten können wir wissen nicht wie
es im flieger zu sein wissen nicht wie
es sich anfühlt als fliege in ein
fliegengitter fand es sein oder
fliegenfänger
wir wissen auch überhaupt nicht ob es
sich als etwas anfühlt oder ob da gar
nichts gefühlt wird das ist in frage
kann die pflege überhaupt emotionen
empfinden kann sie das hat die
ausstattung dazu bekomme ohne frage ganz
klar und ohne frage jedes säugetier ohne
frage
kolportiert wird schon schwierig
krokodile sind nicht so
schmerzempfindlich er hat bei den
wackeren regenerieren sich teile des
salamander durch kann man den schwanz
abnehmen und regeneriert sich wieder
glaube nicht dass die schmerzempfinden
ansehen bei reptilien wird schon viel
komplizierter von vögeln die können
natürlich mehr zu finden ist dann bei
dem zehnten spanischer geht da bin ich
mir selbst nicht ganz sicher
könnte das auch wieder was mit er
frage von einem individuum zu tun haben
also wenn wir jetzt zum beispiel den
tintenfisch wissen wir der kampf
schmerzempfinden das ist glaube ich das
steht fest
und man hat sogar ausgestellt heraus
gekommen um beim beispiel zu bleiben
das tintenfische und sogar eine eigene
persönlichkeit damals hingegen nicht
gerecht und bei ameisen fischen insekten
das hast du gesagt ist es endlich so
dass es um die offizielle aussage
bewogen diese arten von tieren empfinden
schmerz als reit und halt nicht so wie
wir
schmerzempfinden auch keinen psychischen
sondern wirklich als reiz reagieren
also ist schon wieder die frage wie
definieren wir schmerzen nicht super
spannend aber wir kommen dann auch was
gibt es noch für andere empfindungen die
reizvoll sind und dann die frage
vielleicht ist schmerz die beste form
der wahrnehmung von reizen
so ist halt also achtung je liter zion
schmerz irritationen oder system wird
ihren teller und das könnte früher ja
das ist die frage die die haben ja der
verpflichtung lebewesen solche
irritationen die jetzt nicht
phänomenologische könne als schmerz
empfunden werden müssen zu ersparen
das ist die spannende frage die sache
offensichtlich die haben nicht diese
schmerzempfinden wie wir dass es wehtut
aber sie haben eine irritation eine
störung auf diese reagieren müssen
systemfehler hier bluescreen störungen
entfernen irgendwie programm und
erfahren so weit
ich ärgere mich natürlich darüber aber
ich empfinde keine schmerzen
also kann man sich natürlich fragen
sollten wir diese irritationen den
tieren ersparen
leiden sie an diesen irritationen auf
eine wenn wir so weiter runtergehen dann
sind wir auch schon falls bei den
pflanzen pro jahr zulassen werden völlig
richtig pflanzen werden ja auch
irritiert
und wenn ich zum beispiel mäuse auf
pflanzen an setzte dann reagieren die
darstellerinnen hat die reagiert darauf
indem sie gifte absondern oder eben auch
am ende zu grunde gehen
und ich glaube tatsächlich nicht dass
wir eben so weit habe gehen müssen weil
es jetzt aber einfach argument so ein
bisschen adhoc vielleicht weil der angst
der antikommunismus fehlt bei pflanzen
eben nicht aussehen wie lebewesen sind
lebewesen aber ähnliche tiere dass uns
da einfach so die idee revolutionär
motionäre nähe verliert aber ich glaube
hat sich das bloße irritation noch kein
normativ entscheidendes kriterium
handlung zu unterlassen
große irritation ist müsste sich die
subjektive qualität des schmerzes
findens dazu kommt dass wirklich leid
nicht nur dass reaktivieren also wie
kann er sagen schmerzempfinden ist
reagieren plus nix also stören plus
aktive fährt aber es könnte ja denkbar
wir haben einfach nur störung und nicht
bloss sechs kinder stören zum beispiel
irgendwie da der austraße hinter ihnen
und hört zu und so dass das
jagten kein großen schreck ein als sie
leiden damit aber ihre aufmerksamkeit
wird umgelegt aber da darf man nicht
vergessen wenn man eine ameise wir jetzt
davon ausgehen ameise empfindet nur der
störungs werk zur meditation man hackt
ihr halt dem hinteren körper ab dann ist
sie alt ist also dann ist es eine
extreme einstein haben sie aber neue
stationen waren hier habe ich ich würde
das nicht vergleichen mit dem geräusch
im hintergrund das sind es in die
vorhergesagten behalten wird ist die
frage wie die ameise eben drauf täglich
meines würde es sicherlich sein
überlebenskampf revolutionär genetisch
in gang gesetzt werden
und der wäre sicherlich jetzt halte
frage wer diese emotion ehre
überlebenskampf emotional keine monologe
stadt die es erfahren oder wer jetzt ein
windows-system overload bluescreen ja
also ich finde es zum beispiel schon
wichtig denn leid immer im kontext mit
bewusst sagt zu sehen also da haben sie
heute ist mit dem spiegel dass zum
beispiel angeführt ist es gibt nur so
total wohl selbstbewusstsein es dass
distanz ist sozusagen reflektiert und
ansonsten könnte man ja meinen dass sich
die lighthouse also dass man zb tier so
fiel der meiste nicht braucht er das so
selbstbewusst
die unterscheidung ist wichtig da
ansonsten kannst ja das und einfach nur
reis nach zur seite stellen abgebaut und
es sieht für uns vermeintlichen nur
faktisch kein tier selber das nicht so
war
das wäre wieder die das stichwort des
anthropomorphe muss also wir
interpretieren um zu allen formen oder
phänomene in die tiere hinein dass es
andere profis muss und der ist
zweischneidig einerseits erlaubte uns
überhaupt etwas zu finden zu entdecken
weil eben immer schon so denken als ob
es sich um einen menschen handelt es
ästhetisch sehr hilfreich juristisch
also interesse geleitet wir werden sehr
schnell fündig aber wir neigen auch dazu
den andruck kommunismus
überzustrapazieren und in rietavas
glauben finden zu können wo eigentlich
gar nichts ist mehr belegen dass einfach
mal hinter und da müssen wir dann eben
ganz heikel immer auch die
naturwissenschaften heranziehen und das
ganze dann so ausgegeben hat aber fest
steht eben so lange wir meine these also
zusammengefasst da wo kein leben
da auch keine wirklichen intelligenz im
eigentlichen sinne weil da auch kein
interesse weil intelligenz immer
problemlösungskompetenz und
strategieentwicklung ist und da wo das
interesse nur von außen spricht e-tron
oh mann das system herangetragen da
können wir nicht im vollen sinne von
intelligenz sprechen müsste wieder ist
ein relativ intelligenz oder extern
avisierte intelligenz aber wir brauchen
einen begriff von leben und hier stellt
die folgen wie wir dieses leben neu und
modellieren können natürlich
selbstbezüglichkeit ganz wichtig und da
gibt es noch viel zu tun wir werden uns
mit diesem thema in der nächsten sitzung
befassen wo wir uns im weiteren sind mit
künstlern wie cats beschäftigen werde
aber dazu müssen wir eben jetzt immer so
ein bisschen das modell den bewohnern
der zeit verstanden ja also wir werden
diese ganzen probleme und diskussionen
und punkte die wir heute angesprochen
haben für offene sehr beispielhaft eine
gute art und weise wie ich finde
also nachvollziehbar die können wir dann
auch auf digitale netzwerke anmelden bzw
dieselben probleme treten einfach auch
bei der beobachtung und diskussion
dimensionen die darauf gemacht werden
also philosophische dimension die fans
von interesse sind ist eben die
ontologie dass die erkenntnis wie können
die ethische komponente bei der ganzen
diskussion und ich denke wir machen noch
eine kurze zusammenfassung in themen
sendung zu lesen
netzwerk thema und um das einfach
nochmal nachzuvollziehen für die zuhörer
vielen dank an alle die hier waren und
mir ist diskutiert haben und ertrag für
deinen inhalten deine arbeit in dem
bereich genau dann tschüss und bis zum
nächsten
[Musik]